the jurogan experience but i was going
to bring up have you seen the new um the
batman yes
how do you feel i loved it you did you
hated it i hated it tell me why okay
first of all he's total limp dick like
he doesn't even bang
[ __ ] zoe kravitz at the end who's
like the hot ass i kissed her at least
did they french did he francher i mean
it was like a real kiss very chaste
so here's what i think
he's got he's got no dick and balls he's
a reluctant do you really think he has
no digging no dick and balls because
he's a reluctant hero and nothing
aggravates me more here's who batman is
he's [ __ ] bruce wayne he's a
multi-millionaire
he enjoys being batman he enjoys his
cars he enjoys being the powerful hero
he puts on the suit i'm batman remember
[ __ ]
uh
vicki vale and the guy the who's the
beetlejuice when beetlejuice was batman
yeah michael keaton michael keaton
crushed it and he crushed puss and he
was a virile male this batman is like
good [ __ ] feelings his hair is in his
eye and like
what are you doing
wipe your [ __ ] and go be a hero wow
same with spider-man did you see that
horse [ __ ] you didn't like spider-man
either they're all [ __ ] crying the
whole time why are they crying there's
multiverse there's multiple spidermans
and they're all [ __ ] having their
periods at the same time i don't want to
see it show me men i want my heroes you
like the hulk i love the hulk
because that's the dichotomy of human
nature that's the that's jekyll and hyde
it's a very traditional story i love the
hulk his big green hulk [ __ ] i love him
yeah look at him now yeah this is smart
i liked him oh you know who i loved the
christian bank christian bail was the
best batman that was the best one he was
he was pretty good i liked robert
pattinson's batman so tell me i thought
it was good i loved rob robert patterson
you're missed the vampire it's suspect
he was great in that too it's suspension
of disbelief you know like you have this
it's you're watching a goofy ass movie
about a weird
fake world you know where a guy can like
[ __ ] shoot a grappling hook to the
top of a building and it pulls him up
you know it's like you have there's a
lot that you just like take for granted
is nonsense yeah the thing about
batman has always been that batman was
just a rich guy
that that had access to all this money
so he could buy all this [ __ ] and and do
these things yeah which works in a comic
book
it really works in a comic book because
in the comic book like you kind of got
free license for him to create like a
[ __ ] nuclear reactor that he could
put on a jet ski and you know what i
mean like yeah batman has all the money
he can do whatever he wants but in in
movies you're like why is he kicking
everybody's ass how come nobody gets
them how come three guys don't gang up
on them take them down and stab him and
they're shooting
you know rounds and rounds at him
no one in [ __ ] gotham can shoot a gun
he's bulletproof you just don't shoot
him in the chin oh [ __ ] that's right
question so batman could have been he
could have been iron man but he chose
not to be because that's what iron man
is that's a very good point right good
point very good point i don't think
batman is quite as smart as iron he
doesn't have the heart thing which keeps
us bigger iron man is smarter tony stark
is like a legit like super genius back
and then he gets raised he hired people
to make it yeah tony stark is a guy who
became rich what do you want i want
water oh that's water in there tony
stark is a guy who became rich because
he was brilliant i like that
the batman guy
he's just rich yeah in here inherited
yeah he got it from his parents but
bruce wayne is not like a brilliant he's
not a super genius that's a good point
that's the most but here's the deal so i
also i have a very hard time feeling bad
for rich characters like oh i'm an
orphan well who cares we all are okay a
lot of us had shitty parents so you've
got millions of dollars go have fun
right go have fun with this batman i
found him to be very just faye and like
but no one was having fun in the whole
movie the whole movie was my mom died
everyone's dead coke's everywhere so the
whole movie but the whole movie was dark
yeah it's a [ __ ] bummer man i'm i
don't want to be bummed out
i want fun show me some life who's your
favorite um
like superhero character in films
i don't like superman because he's too
american pie i like a little darkness
my favorite's blade go ahead
blake can you bring a blade i'm not even
sure
yeah yeah he's dope he killed vampires i
like vampires i'm 100 on his side okay
plus he's a day walker he's part vampire
how does this work so how does this work
his mother was bit while he was in the
womb so how did he can walk during yeah
you can walk during the day but he's got
vampire powers but they have to keep
giving him injections of blood
because he uh he wants to kill people
and eat them but he doesn't because he's
a good guy
and he knows karate
dude i can see all of this lining up for
you yeah it's my 100
favorite i like that dude
yeah
wesley snipes was [ __ ] badass as
blade 2 was perfect because i was a fan
of blade the comic book where he uh had
teak weapons he used a really hard wood
because vampire's gonna put steak
through their heart yeah so he had teak
steaks that he carried with him